[Музика]
повсякденні люди в Європі користуються
послугами та продуктами пристроїв, які допомагають їм і
досягають їх, заощаджують час і
гроші або просто змушують відчувати себе краще.
Ці інновації були розроблені
завдяки співпраці між партнерами в
різних країнах,
об’єднаних мережею, присвяченою  інновації Eureka
цей свати підтримує підприємців
з більш ніж 40 країн, щоб вони змогли вивести
на ринок свої інноваційні ідеї Eureka for
Europe означає міжнародне співробітництво
та фінансування інновацій поблизу
ринків. У вашому бункері немає іншого інструменту,
який може створити так багато
можливостей для її ринкового руху та
інновація Eureka – це мережа, яка
дійсно відкрита для будь-якого бізнес-
дизайну, щоб догодити нашим клієнтам, які
є ворогами вченим, компаніям
, які шукають підтримку, яка
не буде блокувати рейтинговий доступ до нових
ринків, доступ до нових партнерів, доступ до
нових  образи мислення Eureka — перлина
в європейському ландшафті фінансування досліджень  e
оскільки вона завжди відкрита та не
обмежується конкретними термінами, це
дає нам можливість по-справжньому вчитися
на досвіді інших країн,
тому що це найкраща практика. Мережа
Eureka створена для підвищення
міжнародної конкурентоспроможності Європи
в глобальному масштабі Eureka
відмінно  у мережі для європейських
країн та азіатських країн
Канада розглядає Eureka як
можливість сприяти розвитку міжнародних проектів у
напрямку нових продуктів,
процесів та послуг, це інноваційна
мережа. Мережа справді дуже приземлена, це
справді практична та дійсно дає
результати, я думаю  мова йде про те, що Європа
працює зі світом для створення
кращого майбутнього
[Музика]
[Оплески]
скористайтеся моментом відчуйте, як дихає світло, яке
воно продовжує б'ти
]
ця магія всюди
слухайте
[Оплески]
[Музика]
відкрийте своє серце
[Музика],
бо світ прекрасний  ful
[Музика]
це як ідеальний день,
щоб зловити сонце й потанцювати,
о мій французький, поруч зі мною
гарна
улюблена пісня
[Музика]
[Оплески]
Юріка 30 років ми ніколи не  припинити
інновації Європейська комісія пишається тим, що
зіграла певну роль у створенні Eureka,
фінансованої державою міжурядової
мережі галузевих науково-дослідних інститутів
та університетів у більш ніж 40 країнах,
провідної платформи для міжнародного
співробітництва та відкритих інновацій. Eureka
народилася, коли президент Франції зустрівся з Іраном
і президент Німеччини Коул мав чітке
бачення бачення транскордонного науково-дослідного
співробітництва, яке повинно бути близьким до
промислових ринків, забезпечуючи
технологічну незалежність Європи в секторах 21-го
століття через 30 років по тому,
Eureka може озирнутися на багато успіхів у науково-дослідних розробках,
які покращують життя для  людей
у Європі та в усьому світі Єв
опейська комісія та Eureka були бл
зькими партнерами з самого початку, і Eu
eka ha  з тих пір, як поступово внесла свій внесок
у програми досліджень і розробок по всьому
континенту та за його межами, надихаючи
почуття спільної мети та амбіцій у більш ніж
40 країнах на шляху Eureka
та ЄС разом розробили багато чудових
проектів,
одним із прикладів є, звичайно,
спільна ініціатива програмування ваших зірок зараз у  Його
друге видання «Ваші зірки» продовжує
стимулювати транснаціональні спільні
дослідження, очолювані МСП. Ці
МСП бачать, що їх вплив
посилюється завдяки мережі Arak, оскільки вони
приносять європейські інновації на глобальні
ринки, перетворюючи наукові ноу-хау
та технологічні досягнення в
продукти, послуги та процеси, які
забезпечуйте процвітання в Європі разом, ми
робимо Європу та більш конкурентоспроможною
та стійкою економікою, а також
більш динамічною
та інклюзивною спільнотою, тож дякую,
Eureka та вітаємо з 30-
річним об’єднанням наших найкращих ідей та наших
найперспективніших інноваторів